welcome back so in the last few lectures
we've been talking about balance model
reduction which means you take a
high-dimensional system that you know
you have the system you can simulate it
and you there's a procedure
essentially for finding a coordinate
transformation that gives you a reduced
order model that's much faster to
simulate and it gives you the most
controllable and observable dynamics it
captures the most input-output energy of
your system so that is a very
interesting perspective it's called
model reduction it assumes you have the
model lots of times we do I have the
name of your Stokes equations I know
what fluids do I have the equations of
really complicated multi-joint robots I
know what they do but for lots of
systems all I have is measurement data
okay so what we're gonna talk about now
is system identification to get balanced
models so kind of I'm gonna just call
this balanced system identification sis
ID system identification and what we're
gonna be talking about in in particular
is the eigen system the eigen system
realization algorithm very very very
powerful algorithm is it all the time
algorithm okay one of the rules never
spell in public I consistent realization
algorithm er a this was developed by
Wang and papa
pretty sure Wang and Papa in 1985
okay so very shortly after Moore came
out with his 1981 paper long and Papa
in 1985 came out with this eigen system
realization algorithm which is still my
go-to method for a linear system ID this
is let's say linear linear system ID
I'll tell you all about nonlinear system
ID later super powerful stuff kind of
modern methods based on machine learning
but my go-to linear system ID method is
the eigen system realization algorithm
from Wang and papa
it turns out actually this this took a
couple of decades to figure out but it
turns out that this er a gives a quibble
models to balance p OD balance proper
orthogonal decomposition remember it's
very much equivalent in some
circumstances to BP OD the rally 2005
BP OD and this connection was
established by John wah-wah in a 2011
tea CFD paper you can google John
wah-wah and rally TC FD 2011 and you can
find the connection it's really cool
but remember BP OD and balance
truncation and more and rally always
assume that you had access to this
direct and adjoint system you had your a
B and C matrices or you had a simulation
that could give you data and adjoint
data and the ER a doesn't all that er a
assumes is that you have measurement
data of your complex system and it gives
you an equivalent balanced reduced order
model so it's awesome okay and so this
is going to be an overview I'm gonna
show you what the overview is and then
we're gonna dive into a lot of math
because they're steps and it could get
really kind of hairy so what is the
overview the overview is we are we
assume so there's a basic assumption so
assume that our system is in fact linear
and I'm always going to do this in
discrete time dynamics if I do impulse
responses because it's so much easier we
assume that we have a system this thing
like like this and we're gonna assume
that YK equals C XK and for now I'm just
going to assume that there might be the
possibility of a feed through term so
that my actuation you directly gives an
impact on my measurement Y so I have
these four matrices a B C and E now i do
not assume that i know what these are
all i'm assuming is that my system can
be described the input/output dynamics
of my system can be described in terms
of some some linear system so we also
assume that we measure u and y but not X
directly in fact I don't even know what
the state of my system is I don't know
what those variables even mean I'm
get some latent variables some hidden
variables that are necessary to describe
you and put out but dynamics but they
might have nothing to do physically with
things in my system so we can measure
you and why but we can't measure the big
full state of my system directly this is
kind of the assumption what's the other
assumption so the other assumption I
guess is that I can do what's called an
impulse response experiment okay it's an
impulse response experiment I can do an
impulse response and what an impulse
response is is this you so I'm assuming
I have multiple inputs and multiple
outputs so everything's a vector what an
impulse response is is U u K I'm going
to call it Delta okay I'm gonna call my
impulse response in Delta it assumes
that at time zero I can hit you with a
delta function and then for all future
times U is zero so this is going to be
what is this this is going to be an
identity matrix for k equals zero and
it's going to be a zero matrix for K
greater than zero and this is an
identity matrix because this is a vector
of inputs if it was a single input and
single output this would be easier this
would just be a one i impulsively kick
you equals one at time zero and then I
drop it off to zero afterwards and
what's kind of cool is I can actually
write down my output response
analytically so YK given a delta is
equal to and we're kind of assuming X
naught equals zero initial zero initial
condition so it starts at rest I whack
it with a hammer that's my impulse
response and I measure how the system
evolves so if X was zero at time zero
and I give you an impulse and input then
Y zero equals D okay that's D at time
step K equals zero and then for all
future time steps now X
equals B and then X equal so y equals CB
then X would equal a B and Y would equal
C a B and so on and so forth so this
will be C a to the K minus 1 B for all
bigger all positive okay and so if I was
going to draw this in a picture for
single input and single output you know
I do draw this quite a bit let me give
myself two axes okay then what my u
looks like is this it's unit at time 0
it's just a unit discrete time impulse
this is all discrete times this is an
impulse is like a little rectangle where
it's just on at time zero and it's off
at all future times and what Y is going
to happen is it's going to have some
dynamics that respond and I'm just
making dynamics up as I go it's gonna
have some response that is measured
discreetly in time given that impulse
that's what these these measurements are
so Y is going to you know ring through
the system and what ER a is going to do
what er a tries to do so we're gonna
this is our data okay this is our data
for ER a that's a purely data-driven
it's experimental data I impulsively is
it gives me reduced order a a reduced
order B and a reduced order let's say C
and D of the dimensions so this is a
rank our model so this is our word rank
or model and so I could write down my
system X tilde K plus 1 equals a our X
tilde K plus B R u K Y K equals C our X
tilde K Plus D u K notice I didn't put a
tilde on D because the dimensions of my
you
why the inputs and outputs those never
change I can't reduce those I have five
inputs I keep five inputs I have five
outputs
I keep five outputs so this D matrix is
still size five by five or whatever it
is this can't be reduced but what I can
do is I can learn I'm learning from data
this is really machine learning if you
want to think about it you're learning a
model that describes your data that
generalizes so this is machine learning
it's old machine learning I learned from
my impulse response data the a B and C
matrices of rank are that best
approximate the you to lie dynamics the
measured input-output response so this
is kind of a black box model if you
think about it this is a nice system my
er a system is designed to take use and
give wise in a way that's most
faithfully representing the data of rank
our model given a rank our model that's
what he ra does pretty simple I should
probably tell you why this was developed
let's see if I can draw on my Hubble
Space Telescope it's not the best Hubble
ever drawn but you get the picture so in
1985 you know we were in the space race
this is super exciting we were putting
up the Hubble and the space station and
in the space shuttle and designing all
of these aerospace structures and these
structures generally have vibrational
modes okay um you kick the system you do
something and it oscillate so you're
trying to make it as light as possible
okay so you're trying to make this thing
as light as possible it's going to
vibrate it's gonna have kind of these
structural waves going through it and
this is a pretty hard system to model
from first principles it's hard just
like in the you know that example it's
hard to open a textbook and find the
equation for the Hubble Space Telescope
so instead what long and Papa and others
fan and long men and and there's a lot
of great people that have that are
worked in this field what they do is
they build models and mock-ups or they
run you know big simulations of this
thing and they collect impulse response
data you hit it with a hammer and you
see how the system rings rings through
you collect that measurement data Y and
you directly build a reduced order
for that input/output system okay so
that's where this came from was kind of
aerospace structure of vibrations but
now we're applying this to huge systems
and turbulence control it's applied all
over the place super useful method this
is the roadmap we are going to assume
that all we have is data impulse output
input alpha datum this is what we
actually have as the in this is our
inputs
okay the input is impulse response data
we can measure impulse response data the
assumption is that there's some linear
system that governs the observed
behavior that I was you know that
there's some linear system under the
hood going on here these you know for
small perturbations that's a pretty good
assumption here if I have small
amplitude perturbations this is a pretty
linear system and so you basically
assume that you had a linear system you
write down what would be the linear
impulse response if I had a linear
system and then I basically try to back
out what are the best rank are a B and C
and D matrices that agree with that data
that's what we're gonna do with er a
that's all coming up we're going to work
through how to do this math and we're
also going to talk about how this is
connected to balance model reduction and
balance truncation and balanced p OD
and we'll code it up all right thank you